so we've got commentary and
supplementary angles that was the first
thing that we observed what's a separate
thing something nothing to do with Cohen
two angles Leah what do you say this guy
okay fantastic so we have these guys
being literally vertically opposite to
each other and what does that mean
they're not supplementary other they are
149 and 149 they're equal to each other
right cuz they're vertically opposite
let's write that down we've got what did
we say Leah pqb or bqp
they're both the same I think I'm
generally if we have no other things to
do we generally put him in alphabetical
order bqp and what was the other one
a AQR we said what was the relationship
with them they were vertically opposite
and they're not supplementary in this
case they are what are they hundred
forty nine hundred point nine they're
equal to each other by the way I'm just
after you finish rounding up put your
pens down vertically opposites a bit of
a sneaky word because these guys look
vertical right but what are these guys
see the 31 and 31 they are also
vertically opposite aren't they it's
just that there are verticals a relative
word right like if I if you with me if
you turn your head sideways and look
like that you're like wait a second
that's just vertical from another point
of view okay so they would be vertically
opposite as well we have currently
angles we have vertically opposite
someone who suggests something
completely different all over again
okay fantastic so you can see 360
degrees think back to yesterday what's
the word we used to describe an angle of
that size Russian a revolution very good
so you've got a full revolution all the
way around and if you went to a
calculator if you added up or four of
these or add up your four if you like
you should get 360 right at least if you
measure it okay wait okay now all right
we could we could do this we plays game
a long time Mary don't give me the one
last suggestion before I start I this up
I've got a lot of adjacent ink what does
it jacent mean what is it Jason me yeah
yeah beside each other right adjacent so
these guys were chasing these guys are
adjacent these guys I could go on and on
and on okay Co interior vertically
opposite there's two particular other
features I want to highlight I'm going
to show these to you just because we
would take forever on this though Harry
I have a good guess that you might know
where we're headed here have a look with
me at I'm gonna name some angles and I
want you to help me see if you remember
the word for describing them let's go at
a QR that's this guy over here and also
there's another angle a whole lot of
angles that are equal to this right I'm
gonna look at C are s so that's these
two guys now then we could does anyone
remember what they're called starts with
a c' corresponding very good can we name
those again i'm gonna write them down
i'm gonna squeeze them over here so I'm
gonna say a Q R and angle what did you
say CRS CRS they are that word we just
use was corresponding corresponding and
what do you notice about the sizes of
corresponding angles they are the same
they are equal so these are
corresponding and equal right by the way
these two not the only pair of
corresponding angles right you got these
two they were facing that way can
someone name for me another pair of
corresponding angles can you name them
for me Jessica what do you say
fantastic these two here right so
they're do you agree that they're
corresponding and they're facing the
same direction Louise do you wanna give
me one more pair or you want to give me
a different one another reason oh yeah
go ahead
okay so corporate is actually another
it's kind of another way of describing
the same it's just another piece of
language I think it's pretty much these
guys over here because they're heading
in the same direction yeah that's right
but I wouldn't use cooperating in this
context because it's not a weather
terrorism okay now just one last thing
before I've got one last one here to
measure okay just right get to your
point on what makes them correspond ooh
what is it that makes these guys
corresponding you might want to draw
this on with me and if you have another
color be handy corresponding angles they
face in the same direction right so if
you look at these a QR and here's CRS
you see they're facing downwards as it
were facing the same direction the other
pairs that you mentioned for example see
this 31 and this 31 right they are
facing in the same direction do you
notice that that's what makes them
correspond and what's opposite to that
is when wrong color when we're facing in
opposite directions so I'm going to name
for you lastly let's have a look at I
want to find a good example yeah that's
a good one there since 31 what's the
name of that angle can someone named it
for me yeah Russian nice and that just
that one what's his name is it is an
acute angle it is that's the kind of
angle it is a side B Q are very good so
right with me BQ are and what I'm going
to pair with this time is this guy over
here can someone name for me yeah a
nourish ah okay so I'm about to write
that but can someone tell me what's the
actual name of the angle before I write
a nurses word what's the UM what's that
C ah cute the weather Andrews gave us
was alternate and you can see why we use
this word look at where my arrows are
facing right these are not like
corresponding guys facing in the same
direction
how would you describe the way they're
facing yeah no yeah opposite directions
they're like kind of one going that way
one going that way
all right sort of like a Zed except for
me it's kind of like a backward sin or
it could look like an N that's like turn
sideways any of those are fine I try not
to uh say those because the Zed is
backwards and I'm like that's not what
my Zed looks like so they're alternate
and what's the relationship between the
sizes of the angles they're equal very
good okay
so what we've got is these four kinds of
properties right most of them are very
similar they give you equal angles right
so vertically opposite angles very cool
they're the same corresponding angles
these are the ones that face in the same
direction right they're also equal and
the last one these alternate angles
they're also equal 31 31
can someone tell me what would be
alternative this angle here what's the
name of the angle that's alternate to
this one you'd go ahead Q ah deep now
that's exactly right one of the ways you
can see that is again think about where
other angles facing right if you drew
like a little man here which way is this
angle facing it's kind of going down
isn't it do agree with that and it's
alternate one is not going down it's
going up you see how they're going in
opposite directions that's what gives
you an alternate angle there's only one
relationship between pairs of angles and
they're not equal in this case what was
that relationship is the one we started
with actually Cantor yeah it's right
here right this guy here when you have
Co interior angles like these guys
together or these guys together they're
not equal they are supplementary though
it's a bit sticky there is one in
exactly one situation where they might
actually be equal and supplementary as
well what would they have to be equal to
if they were both there have to be 90
and 90 do you see that
yeah 1990 that would be equiangular and
also supplementary okay